- "Never feel guilty for
the work others have to do
to win in life."
And I read this at 30 years old.
29, 30 years old, I
got ahold of this book
that's very hard
to get ahold of.
He wrote a couple books.
One is called
"Pushing Up People."
Another one is called, "All
You Can Do Is All You Can Do,
But All You Can Do Is Enough!"
But this book is not a, like,
you can't buy it bookstores.
So I got ahold of it, and
it said never feel guilty.
I'm like, "Never feel guilty,
never feel guilty," wow.
Hey, that guy's gotta
pay the price as well.
If he says he's
got this big dream,
he's gotta pay the price,
so never feel guilty.
(pensive music)
- PBD.
- Yes.
- You are officially the
first guest in my new studio,
and I'm very happy to
have you here, my friend.
- Well, first of
all, congratulations
place looks amazing,
and thanks for having me, man.
I mean, when Sam said,
"Pat schedule Craig,"
'cause we're leaving
to New York tomorrow.
- Yeah.
- "Can we make this?"
I said, "It's Dave,
no question about it.
We got to figure it out."
So we got down here
to be here with you.
- There were several
reasons I wanted to do this,
mostly because I
knew you would dress
to the nines to show up here,
(Pat laughing)
and a first guest
has to dress right.
- I like it.
- But that is part
of the PBD operation, right,
like, looking good, dressing
right, taking care of yourself.
It's part of he
kind of whole thing
that has given you success.
- I would say so.
I think, you know,
you gotta know
this is not what I was
used to growing up.
I don't think I've ever
worn a suit as a kid.
Maybe I went to a wedding
one time and wore a suit.
But you go to the
military, you come out,
I'm the baggy pants guy,
size-48 jeans with Dickies.
And you know-
- I've seen some
of the old pictures.
- Yeah.
You do some of those
old throwbacks, yeah.
- That's some of my stuff.
And then I go to the army.
I get out.
In the army I,
start wearing BDUs,
and I started falling in
love with ironing my clothes
with starch from PX and shining
my boots for a couple hours.
I love doing that.
And then when I got out and
started working in business,
and one of my guys at Morgan
Stanley Dean Witter said,
"You gotta get a nice
suit," and then I put it on.
I said, "I kinda like this."
And then, you know, the
rest is obviously history.
- Well, first off, let's do
a little of this.
- Yes.
- Cheers, man.
- Cheers.
Congrats on this.
(glasses clinking)
- Thank you, thank you.
Well, everything that we're
gonna talk about is sort of,
I would say, a
congrats to both of us
'cause we both moved our
lives and operations-
- Yes.
- to this free state.
And it has pretty much
worked since then, sir.
- I agree. I agree.
- So, I will drink to that.
I should note, by the way,
you're doing the whiskey.
You're a whiskey guy.
- You're doing the what?
You're doing the tequila?
- I'm a tequila guy.
- Okay, I tried to
finish all the tequila
in the world, didn't work.
So I gave up.
- Yeah?
- And I moved to whiskey.
- I wanna get you on tequila.
Can I tell you that the bottle,
I think, Connor, can we get a
shot of the bottle behind me?
That's the most expensive bottle
I've ever bought in my life.
- No joke?
- 550 bucks.
- Get outta here.
- For a bottle of tequila.
But I was, like, you know what?
New studio,
things are going all right.
- Good for you.
- I'm sitting down with PBD.
I've had my eye on that
bottle for a long time,
and I went out and
bought it yesterday,
and I was, like,
"We're gonna do it.
- Well, listen, I mean, it
matches your one-bedroom condo
you live in here.
(David laughing)
- Can you believe I
sleep in this room too?
Isn't that something?
(Pat laughing)
I love how, right
before we start,
my producer Phoenix says to you,
"Hey, Patrick, what
kinda watch is that?"
Yeah, without flinching,
"Oh, it's a Fossil, 50 bucks.
- Yeah, it's a Fossil watch.
No, but obviously your
house is a beautiful house,
which you got here.
Congrats to your success
on what you've done going
from where you were at.
You know, I'm asking you,
what are these VHS, you know,
from standup to now being one
of the most powerful
voices out there, man.
It's great to see
what you've done.
- Well, truly
that's why I wanted
to have you in for
this first show
because your
dedication to success
and trying to replicate
that for other people.
I mean, those days when I
was doing that, I was broke.
I mean broke I
didn't have 50 bucks.
I was borrowing change to get
a cup of coffee at Zabar's
on the Upper West Side so
I could do a little standup
at night to pray for the dream.
I had a buddy, this
is totally true.
I had a buddy who worked in
food service for restaurants
who would drop off
industrial size cans of tuna
that I would survive
on for weeks.
Most likely, I'm gonna die of
mercury poisoning, you know.
(Pat laughing)
But that thing,
like, that thing,
the struggle to the success-
- Yeah.
- Tell me, I know your story,
but can you gimme,
like, the brief,
like, struggle-to-success story?
- Yeah, I mean, you talk
about tuna, you know.
When I was in the army,
I would get the tuna
'cause it was disgusting
but the can was,
like, 49 cents at PX,
(David laughing)
and you would mix
it with mustard
'cause at least mustard
would make it tolerable.
And throughout the day,
I would have 3, 4, 5 of these
cans to get the protein.
No, listen, regular-
- Hey, tuna, tuna might be
the key to the whole operation.
- I think that's what it is.
Mercury, we're both
gonna go through,
one day news is gonna come out.
"Dave Rubin and
Patrick Bet-David are
dealing with mercury,
having too much of it," but
no, I mean, look, you know,
it all starts with a dream.
I was talking to a couple
of the guys the other day.
Just yesterday, we were doing
a Zoom call with a couple
of our executives, and
one of my guys says,
"Hey, one of my sales
guys I'm dealing with,
he's very difficult
to deal with.
He's a pain in the ass,
and he's tough to do this,
and da, da, da, da, da."
He's a 1099 guy, not W-2.
W-2, you have the option
to fire, and coach,
and send him to places,
but 1099, you're working
with these guys, right?
It's like you're running
a insurance office
and real estate office.
So he says, "What
do I do with them?"
I said, well, "Let
me tell you what I do
in these types of situations."
I said, "For a guy like me,
I joined the army at 18,
okay, April 15th, 1997."
I get shipped to Fort
Jackson, South Carolina.
My ASVAB score wasn't high,
so I only could be
infantry or mechanic.
So I became a Hummer mechanic.
I had 13 Hummers to myself.
I had a couple FMTVs and LMTVs.
These are the bigger trucks.
And I had a Hotel-8
certification,
which means I can go tow cars
out of the mud, you know,
trucks out of the mud, and
that's what I did for a living.
I thought I was gonna
do 20 years, literally.
I'm gonna be in the
army for 20 years.
Then, I'm gonna get out.
I'm gonna get an additional
10 points on my score
to be working at the post
office, or cop, or firefighter
because if you're
former military,
you get that 10
points on the test.
So if somebody scored 75,
but you're in the
army, you get 85.
If you do 82, you do 92, right?
So I had that advantage.
Then one day, I get a call
from a friend of mine, Kogan.
He says, "Hey, Pat,
what are you doing?"
I said, "Tomorrow, I'm
reenlisting for six years."
"Really?"
"Yeah, I'm reenlisting tomorrow.
They got me everything
I wanted on my orders.
I'm gonna go special
forces, Delta, SERE school.
You know, I speak
five languages.
So they're gonna help me
out to sharpen my language.
And then I'm gonna
go to Vicenza, Italy,
which is where I
wanted to go to.
There was a
beautiful unit there.
And then from there, you know,
I'm gonna to do
this for 20 years,
and I'm gonna retire
at 38 years old,
and then I'm gonna go be
a cop and firefighter.
He says, "Pat, you
gotta get out."
I said, "I'm not getting out.
I'm signing my contract
tomorrow for six years,
and I'm getting my Army
Commendation Medal."
I had gotten an Army
Achievement Medal.
Tomorrow was a celebration.
Lieutenant Colonel
Peacocks was gonna give me
an Army Commendation Medal.
He says, "Can I
convince you otherwise?"
I said, "You can."
My dad already sent me
a $250 camera as a gift
for committing to reenlist.
He says, "Just gimme an hour."
And this guy was the only guy
that ever came and visited me
in the army outta my
friends for 18 days.
And when you're in the
army, you're alone.
You remember all the letters.
I kept every letter,
every single letter
anybody ever wrote me
while I was in bootcamp.
I have all of it till
today, all of it.
And you know, like,
who's a friend,
and who's thinking, and
who's not, all of 'em.
The people you thought
they're your best,
they never wrote you a letter.
The people you thought
were, like, they were okay,
they wrote you 50, 60 letters.
So I'm sitting
there, hour later.
It's now 1:00 in the morning.
I got formation
early in the morning.
I can't sleep all night.
I've already promised my
dad I'm gonna reenlist.
He wants me to stay in
uniform, be in the military.
I get out in the morning, go
to Lieutenant Colonel Peacocks.
"Disappointing news for
you, I can't reenlist.
I gotta get out."
"Bet-David, what are you doing?
We got you the orders."
I said, "You have no clue
how much I respect you,
but I'm getting
out," so I get out.
They don't give me the
Army Commendation Medal.
- How difficult were
those few hours?
- Wasn't easy.
I mean, I'm thinking
about it right now.
I'm going back because I threw
my boots over the, you know,
you celebrate, like,
"Hey, this is it."
It wasn't easy. Let me tell you.
It was a lot of anxiety because,
when you're in the military,
it's so regimented,
it's so, like, routine,
and if you like routine,
there's a lot of trust
and comfort in routine.
There's order,
there's expectation,
there's a time for formation.
It's a lotta good things,
your benefits, chow hall,
when you eat, how much you
get paid, your promotions,
correspondence courses
you gotta take, you know,
you'll be an E-5, E-6, E-7.
Eventually, you'll
be a drill sergeant,
maybe a, you know,
first sergeant, then
sergeant major, E-9.
And that's kind of
the route you go.
And you can take
advantage of GI Bill,
maybe become an officer,
a second lieutenant,
first lieutenant,
work your way up.
So there was an immediate,
and you can travel,
see the world.
You know 20 years what
it's gonna look like.
It's predictable.
And I like the
predictable aspect.
But I also have a
uncertainty aspect.
The unknown fires me up.
There's an element of
unknown that's exciting,
that level of curiosity.
I wanna know what the
possibilities are.
So then, I get out.
I get outta the military,
I come out to be
a Hummer mechanic.
And there was one
shop at Camarillo,
and it was Thousand
Oaks, Camarillo
that had a Hummer dealership,
so I go, and I said,
"Listen, I'm the
best Hummer mechanic
in Fort Campbell, Kentucky."
And the guy says, "Listen
man, we sell maybe one
or two Hummers a month, H1,
we have one mechanic
if we're lucky.
We don't need a second one."
And I said, "I'm very
good at shooting."
He says, "Listen, we don't
need a hitman here, you know.
You're not gonna
use it in private."
So at that point I went and
took the test to be a cop.
I had 16 speeding tickets,
so I couldn't be a cop.
And then firefighter,
there was a hold.
And then boom,
(fingers snapping)
five-year freeze on
being a firefighter.
Then, I get out and
start making money
in the financial sector,
Morgan Stanley, Transamerica.
Then, I start my own
insurance company,
and the rest is history.
The point I was making
with this meeting was
the level of grace
God has on us.
When you go back and think
about the people you met
in your life, some of them were,
they made such a big
impact in your life,
but they're a five-minute
person in your life.
You're at Nordstrom's.
Your son is wrestling with you.
A woman over here who's 65
years old's looking at me
for 10 minutes while me
and Dylan are wrestling.
I said, "Ma'am, how you doing?"
She said, "I'm doing good."
She said, "Do you know
why I'm looking at you?"
I said, "Why are
you looking at me?"
She said, "Because I remember
when my kids were that age."
Hmm.
I said, "Tell me
about your kids."
"I have three sons."
"How are they doing?
What do they do?"
"One's a doctor,
one's an engineer,
and one's a lawyer."
"Really, all successful?"
"All successful."
"All married with kids."
"Give me three secret sauce.
What was it?"
Said, "I'll only give you one."
I said, "What's that?"
She says, "If you ever threaten
to discipline your kids,
follow through."
I was, like, "Out of all
the advice you can give,
you give me this?"
If you threaten them,
always follow through
because your word
can't lose weight.
- Yeah.
- This is five years ago.
I'm at Nordstrom's.
That lady was in my
life for five minutes.
That impact is permanent.
You got certain people
that are one day,
certain people that are a month,
certain people that are year,
certain people
that are a decade.
But if you think, like,
if you have a relationship
with the man upstairs,
and you say, "How did this
person come into my life?
What is the chance of
me meeting this person?
What?
I'm the luckiest man alive.
So when you look at it
from that perspective,
and then now when I
wake up in the morning,
at the beginning, you and
I were, you know, joking
about poisoning the
drink, and I told you,
I said, "If God
takes me today, man,
I've lived the most
incredible life.
I am so grateful.
Everything from here
is dessert and bonus."
And you know, that's a
brief element of the story
I haven't told before.
- Do you try to
acknowledge that every day?
I sense that you do
from watching your show
and just watching what
you're doing on Instagram
'cause I've noticed for me,
and maybe this is partly
just being a new father,
like, I really am, like,
things have been good.
Like, I don't want
anything else.
It's good. It's really good.
I'm doing what I'm
supposed to be doing.
I have the family
I'm supposed to have.
I'm, like, unbelievably
humbled by that.
And I don't know
what to do with it-
- Yeah.
- sometimes in a way.
- It's interesting you say that.
So to me, this is the
battle I have, right,
because I have friends of
mine who made their money
that no longer wanna work,
and they're living the life
where it's like,
"Well, you know,
Kobe had the father
time that came.
You know, LeBron's
father time is coming.
I'm kinda going through
the father time myself."
People will say this, right?
And I'll say, "Cool,
to each his own,
totally respect it, salute to
you," but I can't help myself.
I tend to challenge
everybody around me,
family, friends, kids.
If you're around me,
you're either gonna like it
'cause I'm gonna challenge you,
or you're not gonna
like it, you know,
'cause you, "This
is too much, man.
I can't be around this guy too
much 'cause it's constantly,
like, the next level
and the next thing."
- [David] Yeah, yeah.
- But you have to
realize, as tough as I am
on everybody else, I'm
a lot tougher on myself.
The way I process this
is the following way.
I'm greedy and selfish
in the following way.
I watched a movie
"Meet Joe Black."
That completely messed me up.
I've never seen the
movie "Meet Joe Black"
till two months ago.
- Brad Pitt, right?
But I don't think I've seen it.
I don't think I've seen it.
- Oh, I mean, let me tell you,
I can't tell you how
ridiculous this movie is.
- Okay.
- The Vault Conference
we held with Brady
two weeks ago-
- Yeah, that was pretty awesome.
- I talked about "Meet Joe
Black" for two, three days
because the scene opens up
with Brad Pitt shows up,
and Brad Pitt is death.
I'm not gonna give you the
whole story, but he says,
"I'm death," and he
keeps rubbing his chest,
you know, Anthony Hopkins,
one of the greatest actors
of all time because he's
having a heart attack,
and death comes and
says, "Your time is here.
You're about to die."
He's 65 years old.
His oldest daughter is putting
together the big party.
Presidents are showing up.
Senators are showing up,
Billionaires are showing up.
And here's a businessman
that's a billionaire,
gets in a helicopter from
Hamptons, goes to Manhattan,
does business, comes
back, and you know,
that's the life he's living.
And he's so close
with his daughters.
They love him.
Youngest daughter's kinda,
like, his right-hand person
that's doing stuff
with business.
And she's dating the
other right-hand guy.
And this house is,
like, a behemoth
60,000-square-foot house
and impact, investments, board.
And I'm watching this movie.
I'm like, "Oh, my God,"
fired me up because
it gave me urgency
'cause my dream was always to
have the family live close.
I want all my kids close to me.
Obviously, they don't have to.
They get to do
whatever they wanna do.
But I'm gonna bust
my tail to have
so many different opportunities
where if you wanna be
a realtor, you can manage
our real estate portfolio.
If you wanna be a
lawyer, we need lawyers.
If you wanna go do movies,
let's go fund your movies.
If you wanna go be a teacher,
let's build a school together.
- They could be dog walkers
'cause I saw a video
that you did-
- Anything.
- (laughing) where your kids
are now making some money
dog walking.
- Yeah, dog walking.
Any, you wanna be a
capitalist, go do it.
But let's stay together because
I want us to stay together
as a family, and I'm gonna do
my best to create that net.
And then at the same
time, the other side,
you know I wrote this book
called "Choose Your
Enemies Wisely"
that comes out December 5th.
A lotta people say, you know,
"Why choose your enemies wisely?
Why not choose your
friends wisely?
allies wisely?"
I really think this is a season
where enemies are truly
formidable enemies
that requires people who are
capable to fight to stand up.
And I take that
role very seriously.
I teach my kids, "If somebody
in school is getting bullied,
and you can do something
about it, you gotta stop that.
If you don't, you're a coward."
So in a way, if I'm
teaching this to my kids,
and I'm watching what's
going on in America,
what's going on with, you
know, these guys telling Rumble
what to do from
House of Commons,
"Hey, you guys better
take this guy down,"
and consider what YouTube did
to them from UK is telling
Rumble, a Canadian
company based out of,
who the hell are you
to say something?
Or what they're
doing to parents,
and you got 30 different cities
who are in Canada protesting
right now against
indoctrinating kids
and have so much respect
for these parents
that are willing
to do the fight.
I'm sorry, some people
maybe don't have a platform
like you and I.
Who am I to wanna sit here and
just celebrate all this money
I've made, the house I have,
the, you know,
relationships I have.
I feel like this is an
era where God is looking
for, you know, the flag
carriers to rise up,
and we feel we wanna earn
the right to be one of them.
- Did you have to do work to
not feel guilty over success?
Because the mainstream
idea of success,
everyone wants to pretend
it's only worthwhile
if you came from nothing.
- Right.
- It's only worthwhile
if you have nothing,
if you're always struggling.
But if you came from anything
or you have anything,
you should be guilty about
it or feel bad about it.
And I actually remember
the first time that I went
to your show, which was soon
after moving to Florida,
and you guys loved
success so much.
And obviously, the last couple
years have been good to me.
And it has been a
shift in my mind
to not feel any shame around it.
I feel pride over it.
I mean, I've built this.
I work with great people.
I talk to people like you,
but you have to, like,
do work to do that
'cause you have to overcome
what society's telling
you about success.
- You know, it's a great point.
I read a book once by a
man named Art Williams,
a man I look up to a lot.
He's a great leader.
He went from being a regular
guy in the insurance industry,
built a company,
became a billionaire,
bought an NHL team, and
just great family guy.
I think he's been married for
50 something years to his wife
if not longer, and he's impacted
a lot of people's lives.
In one of his books, he says,
"Never feel guilty for
the work others have to do
to win in life."
And I read this at 30 years
old, 29, 30 years old.
I got ahold of this book that's
very hard to get ahold of.
He wrote a couple books.
One is called
"Pushing Up People."
Another one is called, "All
You Can Do Is All You Can Do,
But All You Can Do Is Enough!"
But this book is not a,
like, you can't buy
it in bookstores.
So I got ahold of it, and it
said, "Never feel guilty."
I'm like, "Never feel guilty,
never feel guilty, wow."
Hey, that guy's gotta
pay the price as well.
If he says he's
got this big dream,
he's gotta pay the price,
so never feel guilty,
what a point.
Kids, never feel guilty.
If your kid wants it,
he's gotta pay the price.
Yesterday, Jay Williams,
you know Jay Williams,
the basketball player.
- Yeah.
- We were together
till midnight.
He's at the house.
He's talking to Dylan.
Dylan's an athlete, so
he wants to play sports,
super competitive, so he says,
"So Dylan, so tell me,
tell me about yourself.
He says, "Well, I play this,
this, this, this, that."
He says, "How good are you?"
He says, "I'm a good athlete,
but I'm a little too
competitive sometimes,
and I wanna win all the time."
He said, "Let me
show you a video."
He shows the video.
He sits down on the stairs,
and he's showing
Dylan this video,
Jay Williams talking to Tom
Bilyeu on "Impact Theory"
about a story of Kobe Bryant.
This video went viral.
And he says, "One
day, we're shooting.
I'm doing 400 shots.
I wasn't gonna leave
till I make the 400."
You've probably seen this video.
- [David] Yeah,
I've seen it, yeah.
- And Dylan's, like,
enamored by it.
We're just kind
of watching this.
And he's like, "Wow,
that's pretty wild on what,
you know, Kobe did to
get to where he's at."
So then, he's teaching my son,
"Hey, if you really
wanna go there,
you're gonna have
to pay the price
'cause this guy paid the price."
I can't feel guilty for my
son having to pay the price.
So if others don't wanna do it,
I don't feel guilty for you.
So then the next phase
becomes for us is
you came from nothing.
You're broke when you're doing
this, you know, comedy, standup,
and then now you're living
in an incredible home
here, and you have weight.
Your voice carries weight
where people want
your endorsement.
People want to see
what Dave has to say.
You've spoken to some of
the most powerful names
around the world, and you
are many people's dreams.
One day, people want to
follow your footstep.
Well, they gotta pay
the price for it,
but the challenge is
gonna be for our kids.
Our kids are gonna go
through the other part.
"Well, listen, you're a
rich kid, and you're this,
and you're that,
and you're this."
I'm reading this book
by Joseph Kennedy,
and Joseph Kennedy, in
his book when you read it,
one of the things he didn't
wanna do is never wanted
to give credit to his parents
because he wanted to say,
"I did it myself."
So you know, as you
go into this phase,
our kids' challenge is gonna
be different than ours.
Last night, I'm really
challenging one of my kids
hardcore right now, and
my wife and I are having
a conversation 'cause we're
reading Musk's new book,
phenomenal book by the way.
I don't know if you've
gone through it yet.
- I haven't gone through it yet.
- Phenomenal,
phenomenal, just a very-
- It just came out
a couple days ago.
- It just came out.
- Man, you're on it.
You're on it.
- It just came out,
the story with him,
Kimbal, sister,
two hours he would walk to this,
and how he would get
into fights, and bullied,
and the way his dad
was, and why he lived
with his dad and Kimbal, just
a very interesting story.
And it's like, "Babe, you know."
I said, "Babe, you need
to listen to this book
because you have to know one
of our kids is wired this way,
so we have to
understand him better."
And she says, "But you
know, you think we're being
a little bit too tough?"
I said, "Babe, if
life is gonna be,
everything's gonna be easy,
and perfect, and no challenges,
like, we need to create a
little bit of challenges
for our kids to be tougher,
and that's the element
of, as a parent, we
need to be creative.
And that's not easy to do
because we have the resources
to make their lives very easy.
It's gonna be very
challenging for us.
And then, we at the same
time need to have them
have their own identity, but
one of the lessons I learned is
we can't feel guilty for the
price others have to pay.
- Does the fame part
feel weird to you?
Because I mean, you
were an insurance guy,
and a business guy, and you
were giving business talks,
and now it's like you're talking
to presidential candidates
and all the people
I'm talking to.
I was a comedian.
Like, the idea of fame
was, like, built into the,
I never was doing it to be,
maybe subconsciously I was.
I wasn't consciously
doing it that way.
But, like, fame was gonna be
an extension of what I did.
You go into insurance,
you're not going,
"I'm gonna be famous one day."
- Yeah, yeah, no, listen,
to be famous in insurance,
it means nothing.
(David laughing)
- It means you did
something really illegal.
- (laughing) For
you to be, "Wow,
what a famous
insurance agent, right,
the way he signed that contract
is just incredible, right?"
- That guy moved
a lot of freaking-
- A lotta paper.
- Death certificates.
- There is no,
like, "Sports Center."
♪ Da, na, na, da, na, na ♪
"Patrick Bet-David,
watch the way
he signed this
insurance policy."
There ain't no such
thing like that, right?
So it's kinda weird.
So no, but I think what I
like about it is the evolution
of it, where it wasn't sudden.
What is very tough is no
one knows who you are.
Boom, here we go.
Like, Deion's son right now,
you're seeing the amount
of fame he's getting.
- [David] Yeah.
- But he's had the best
mentor to coach him for Deion
'cause Deion was,
you know, the face,
you know, the greatest
athlete, I would say,
of all time what he's
done, just athlete,
not winner, athlete,
the greatest.
I put him number one, I put
Bo two, I put LeBron three.
The greatest
winners of all time,
I got MJ and Brady at the top.
Then, it's a couple other guys.
- This is a sidebar-
- Athleticism.
- but you think that's just
purely two-sport athleticism?
- Oh, his 40, the way he
played, you're hitting 324-
- Yeah.
- for the Atlanta Braves.
And you know how hard that-
- '92-ish?
- Yeah, '92,
'93.
- Somewhere around there?
- That whole team with I
think it was Pendleton,
Galarraga, all those guys
that they had, David Justice.
I think that's the year
all the crazy pitchers,
Smoltz, Glavine, Maddox
they had, so yeah.
But to me, some people don't
have the coaching of fame.
So you see some of these
guys on social media
where they all of
a sudden get fame,
and they start acting dumb,
and they act, you know.
But you know, we have to also
be patient for some of them
'cause they're
gonna go through it.
For us, the advantage we have is
it's not like all of a sudden
1,000 people are waiting
outside saying, of
"Oh, my God, Dave."
It starts off with,
"Are you that guy?"
- Yeah, "Are you that guy?"
- You start off with that guy.
- Or, "You look like that guy."
- "You look like that guy."
- "You look like Dave Rubin."
- That's it.
- I'm like, "Wow."
- You know what I love to say?
I say, "No, that's
actually my twin brother.
I can't stand the guy.
If you only knew who he was,
(David laughing)
you wouldn't like him as much
'cause you need to know
the truth about him."
But no, the benefit we
have, it's evolution.
It's slow. It's gradual.
Then, there is the
boom, but by that time,
you've been trained.
- Can I tell you the wackiest
one of those that I saw?
- Sure.
- It was a guy
that you've interviewed
and met many times.
Jordan Peterson, you know,
and I was touring with him
for a year and a half,
and think about it.
This guy's a clinical
psychologist.
So he spent most of his
life, he was teaching also,
but spent most of his life
helping people get off drugs
one on one like this, privately.
Then, he becomes basically
the most famous person
in the world overnight.
And everywhere we went, we'd
get to airports in Sweden,
and there'd be 200
people waiting for us
because they got
their life in order.
And he would talk to
every single one of them.
I never saw the guy
be rude, or ignore,
or walk away from
anybody, and it was, like-
- But I will tell you this.
- Geez.
- But I'll tell you this.
I also will say he also
didn't know how to handle it.
Hear me out.
- To an extent, yeah.
- Hear me out.
- I was with him during that.
- Yeah, so I remember, not
from the, you know, arrogant.
I'm not talking
that stuff at all.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I'm talking about, you know,
one day, I'm having him on.
And for about 30 minutes,
he talked about how
much tweets bother him.
- Yeah.
- And he really didn't like
what people were
saying on Twitter.
And I was kind of shocked
by him saying this.
This is five years ago, first
time I had him on the show.
And then, I brought
him back at an event
in 2019 at the Mirage.
This is the event where
we had President Bush,
Kobe Bryant, the
late Kobe Bryant.
This is that event.
- I wanna talk about that.
Yeah.
- This is that event,
and he's speaking,
and he's crying half the time.
And I'm like, "He's
going through something,"
and I asked him a
couple questions.
I'm like, "He's going
through something."
That's the last
interview he does,
and then he goes through the
phase that he went through,
and he openly talked about
how he dealt with it,
how challenging it was for him,
and then the comeback
on what he's done,
and what his daughter's done.
Both of them, I mean,
and obviously, Jordan
Peterson is a powerhouse.
He's a, you know,
force of nature.
And he's duplicating
it with his daughter.
And that's where
the respect goes,
that your daughter is
carrying the torch.
And I can only imagine
where she's gonna
be later on in life.
She's already crushing it.
But imagine what that's
gonna be in 10 years.
- So I wanna talk to you
about that Kobe thing.
We talked about it one other
time when you were on the show,
but so you basically
did the last big,
was it the last
interview with Kobe?
Or was it the last-
- It wasn't the last.
- It was certainly the last big-
- Right, yes.
- interview with Kobe.
Kobe, we're both
basketball guys.
We picked our top fives.
I still think mine beats yours,
but that's where
we do that later.
But Kobe, I think maybe I
told you this privately.
I can't remember.
Two or three days before
he died, I was watching,
I was just flicking the
channels, and I flicked past,
I lived in LA at the
time, and I flicked past
Comcast Sports or whatever,
whatever the Lakers are on.
And I saw Kobe, and I
hadn't seen him in a while.
He had a beard, and he
looked like a million bucks.
That was my thought, "He
looks like a million bucks."
And I stopped, and I watched,
and just the way he spoke,
that calmness that
he spoke with,
and always licking his lips,
and, like, he was just ready
to chew the world, and I
watched for about five minutes,
and I swear to God this is true.
I remember thinking,
"This is a guy who
has done life right."
That was either
the day or two days
before he was dead.
(Pat exhaling)
And then, the day he
died, I saw it on Twitter.
I immediately began to tear up.
I was on tour with
Jordan at the time.
I was about to get in an Uber.
I get in the Uber, and it's a
young black guy as the driver.
He's hysterical crying 'cause
he must have just found out
at that moment,
hysterical crying.
I said to him, "I know
it's Kobe, I know."
And I was very early, so I said,
"We don't have to go
anywhere for a while.
You wanna just talk
about Kobe for a while?"
And we spent about a half hour-
- Get outta here.
I swear to God-
- Wow.
- just talking about
the 81-point game,
you know, the Denver game when
he flew in after the legal,
like, everything, everything.
And I remember thinking, like,
"Man, that guy, two days ago,
I'm thinking he's
living the dream."
Whatever the secret of the
universe is, he unlocked it.
- Mm-hmm.
(fingers snapping)
- Gone like that,
and you sat with him
and had, I think, one
of the best interviews
that he's ever had.
I don't even know
what my question is
other than, what do
you do with that?
What do you do
with that concept?
- Yeah, you know, Kobe's
an August 23rd, 1978, baby.
I'm an October 18th, 1978 baby.
We're six weeks apart.
- Man, you guys are kids.
I'm '76.
Look at you.
- You're '76?
But you look younger than me.
- Yeah, it's-
- You look better than me.
- It's the moisture
here in South Florida.
(both laughing)
- So when he came, and they
traded him for Vlade Divac-
- Vlade Divac, yeah.
- Obviously,
we were devastated.
We didn't want lose
Vlade because Vlade's
a top-five center,
greatest center of all time.
- What, what?
- Hence the sarcasm.
Hardcore sarcasm.
(David laughing)
- Wow, you see,
that didn't get by me.
- I'm glad you caught it.
- (laughing) Come
on, top-five center.
He was good. He
was a good passer.
- I loved Vlade.
- Yeah, no, no.
- But he's not Kobe.
- Slow, yeah.
- I loved
when he scored the points,
put his hands beyond his back.
He went to Magic Johnson.
I just love Vlade.
- I would've never lived
that down if I had missed that.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- That would've been...
(David laughing)
- So you know-
- Top-five Czechoslovakian
or Yugoslavian, I guess.
- Yeah, and by the way,
I think he's a GM or
something for Sacramento.
I don't know if he still is or
not, but I like his swagger.
- And those Sacramento teams
are awesome, different.
- Yeah, phenomenal, him,
Christie, and all those guys,
you know, Stojakovic,
great team.
But you know, it was like,
"I'm gonna go to this place.
I'm not an athlete.
You're gonna go to this place.
But listen, man, I'm gonna
bring the Mamba mentality
in my own way in the
insurance space and boom.
And then later on in 2019,
there's a video of me dressed
as Doc from "Back
to the Future."
- I don't think I've seen this.
- And it's a video.
I'll show it to you afterwards
'cause it's not public.
And I'm saying one day, this
is 2011, I have Doc's hair.
I'm wearing a whole thing.
This event we're running,
I brought the DeLorean.
I'm doing a whole skit
from stage with myself
and a couple of our guys,
John, Fred, Terrance,
and all these guys.
We're doing what we're doing.
And I said, "One day," 2011,
I haven't even started
a YouTube channel yet.
And I said, one day the
great Kobe Bryant will be
on our show, and we'll
be having an interview,"
and da, da, da, da, da.
So that vision was cast,
and eight years later,
Kobe's at the event.
Our guys can't believe
this is happening.
And he comes in.
Hour and a half we spend in
a conference room together
before he hits the stage.
He talks to Dylan
for 15 minutes.
Dylan at the time
was five years old.
He talks to Jen for 15 minutes.
They have the best
conversation together.
Then, a 70-year-old woman,
75-year-old woman comes in,
very nicely put together.
And he runs up to her.
They hug each other and they
have the nicest conversation
where you can tell
the level of respect
and love he has for her, and
I don't know who she was,
but there was a certain
level of relationship
towards each other.
And he says, "So
Pat, do these types
of interviews live
make you nervous?"
I said, "Nah, I'm good."
He says, "Ah, me neither.
I've played in front
of 20,000 people."
I said, "Nah, I totally get it.
I mean, you're Kobe.
I don't see you, but
I'm good at this point."
Then, we hit the stage.
A thousand people run up.
We had to call the security.
The benefit we had, because
the president was coming,
we had 100 Secret Service.
(David laughing)
So everything was pushing 'em
out, and then we sat down,
we did the interview, and
obviously, the rest is history.
But the day when he passed away,
we were at Seasons 52
in Dallas, in Plano.
And my phone says, "Kobe
Bryant, helicopter."
Jennifer looks at CNN.
We're like, "What?"
Then, I go to ESPN. "What?"
Twitter 'cause you know,
sometimes these hoax, you know,
and this is not funny.
- And you can't believe it.
You can't believe it.
- And then Dylan is like,
"Wait, my friend, Kobe?"
So yeah, I mean,
I was pretty wild.
But you know what it is,
what you're saying here,
that's the whole concept
where you have to
enjoy the process,
even when you're in
the grind, driving,
to know that at any point this
can be taken away from you,
- Yeah.
- just enjoy it
because in some ways, people
take that message and say,
"That's why I don't
work that hard.
What's the purpose
of working that hard?
If I know I'm gonna die one day,
why am I doing all this stuff?"
That's also not the
right way of thinking.
I wanna work hard
with the people I love
and using the talents
that God gave me.
But if he takes me
today, I'm good as well
because at the end of the day,
you have no clue what
that day's going to be.
- Do you consider
yourself political?
'Cause we're crossing
paths now a lot,
and the type of people
that are watching us are
very similar in the
political sense of things.
But I can never tell if
you really are political.
Like, I saw you
at the GOP debate.
That's a pretty political thing.
I go on your show.
We talk about politics.
Wait, you didn't do the
DeSantis thing yet, right?
- No.
- It was scheduled, but then-
- They rescheduled-
- But then the hurricane-
- four or three times, yeah.
- The hurricane hit also.
- Yes.
- 'Cause he was going to
you, and then he was coming
to me that afternoon.
- Right, right.
- And then the hurricane hit.
But obviously, you're
political in the things
that you talk about, but
do you consider yourself
a political person?
- What does a
political person mean?
How would you define that?
- Like, you really like
the game of politics.
- Oh, I do.
- You really like the,
not like, you're passionate
about the issues.
Like, you really-
- I actually do.
- think about all of the issues.
- I do.
My parents got a
divorce, you know.
I watched these guys
get two divorces
and remarry each
other twice, right?
And-
- Wait, what?
They-
- My parents got married.
- They married and
divorced twice?
- They got married.
My sister's born.
They get a divorce.
Two years later, they remarry,
I'm born, then they
get a divorce again.
That's my-
- And that was it, though?
They didn't get
back together after that?
- That was it, done.
They can't, if they're
in the same room-
- Oh.
- They're gonna resurrect
a god.
- You've got a movie
on that one.
- Yeah.
- Where are your movie people?
- But my mother's side, a
lot of them were communists.
And my dad's side, a lot
of them were imperialist.
These guys loved the Shah.
They hated the Shah.
These guys, you know,
loved capitalism.
They hated capitalism.
They loved Karl Marx.
That was their Bible.
Stalin, he was a great
leader for Russia, USSR.
All these rich, greedy
people in America,
all they care about is money.
We care about family.
Why would you work that hard?
You should come home at 3:00
and have watermelon and
cheese, and cut it up,
and sit down and have a
conversation together.
Who cares about
the car you drive?
Who cares about this,
this, this, this, that?
And I watched this, so for me,
I didn't like politics
because I saw the fact
that the two people I love
the most got a divorce
because of politics.
But then-
- That was really it?
It was-
- Oh, oh, oh,
brother.
- It was deep down political.
- Oh, my God.
- Wow.
- I mean, one of them,
their philosophy was
rich people are greedy, and
all they care about is money.
And the other one was
poor people are lazy.
- Like, you just
can't get over that.
It's just like-
- And that was just ingrained.
(fingers snapping)
But at that time
it wasn't politics.
It was more like,
why did these guys,
"Why'd you guys get
married in the first place?
Thank God you did,
but why'd you get married
in the first place?
What was the whole
purpose behind it?"
So then I go to Germany, and
then we come to the States.
And when I come to the States,
I go to the army.
That was the first time
where military, you
know, stuff was going on.
President Bush and
Clinton and all this kind
of stuff was going
on, and I'm, like,
"Interesting what's
going on here."
Then, I went into financial
services and started competing.
And then, I realized politics
is involved in insurance,
Department of Insurance.
Politics is involved
in being a cop,
being a firefighter, running
a business, regulation,
financial industry, SEC, NASD.
It's involved everywhere.
And then, when we were a
small insurance company,
politics doesn't do
anything for you now.
You're small. Nobody
caress who you are.
You're tiny.
Then, when we got bigger,
and then all of a sudden,
we have a business
that's national,
we're appointed in 49 states,
and we have offices
all over the country,
a few hundred offices, then
you notice there's a lot
of politics involved.
(David laughing)
All the guys that
were all nice to you,
now they're, like, you know,
"Oh, you can build
anything you want.
You can be as big as you want."
And then they're, like, "Oh,
shit, he actually became
as big as they wanted."
Now, it's, like, "You took
business away from us,
and you're this,
and you're that."
I'm like, "Oh, so
there is politics."
Then, you go, and
you start studying.
I had dinner with George
Will in 2009, March,
with Claremont Institute,
and I go to this event,
and I watch what, you
know, he's talking about
with Larry Arnn, and Larry
Greenfield, and all these guys.
And I'm going to these
events with the owner
of Public Storage
at, you know, Malibu.
And I'm having these
meetings with John Voight,
and you know, Dennis
Prager's coming.
Then, I launch a show
in 2009 with KKLA, KRLA
called "Saving America."
A year later, I shut it down
because my San Francisco
office closed down.
They said, "I cannot
believe you started a show,
and you know, how dare
you do this kind of?"
I'm like, "Wait a minute.
What's going on with politics?"
Then one day, I'm in my
office in Woodland Hills.
(hand knocking)
"Yeah, who is this?"
"Yeah, you owe a, you know,
tax assessor, we're here.
You owe us, whatever, $85,000."
Said, "For what?"
"You're in the district.
You have to pay.
You're growing. Your
business is growing.
This is how much money owe."
I said, "What are
you talking about?"
I call my accountant
who's downstairs
under, you know, our
floor, eighth floor.
I say, "What is this all about?"
He says, "Well, if
they caught you,
and they're coming around,
they knock on doors that are
growing, it's hit and miss.
If they don't come to you,
you don't have to pay it."
- Wow.
- "But if they come to you,
and they know you're
a growing business,
they can tax you."
- LA.
- "You're in this district."
I said, "Are you serious?"
So we had to pay this check.
Then, I said, "What districts
don't they have this?"
"13 of them, Victorville,
Santa Monica,
Burbank, blah, blah, blah."
I said, "Okay, I'm gonna
go to Burbank, Glendale.
So we move our headquarters
to Burbank, Glendale,
so I don't have to
worry about this.
And we're in Glendale at
the New York Life building.
And then all of a
sudden, I'm like,
"Nope, we're not staying here."
"Time Magazine" comes
out with the article
"United States of Texas."
Then, we go to Texas.
We have a meeting
with Governor Perry,
with Maher Maso from Frisco,
was the fastest
growing city in Texas.
Then, we go to a Rangers
game with Nolan Ryan,
and we watch how these
guys are recruiting
businesses to Texas.
This is when Rick Perry
would go to California.
He would do radio shows.
"If you don't like the business
they're taking care of you,
we gonna take care of
you here in Texas."
And we are like, "Okay, great."
So then we moved to Texas.
We fell in love with Texas,
and then COVID happens.
Politics goes to a
whole different level.
My content was always around
business, mafia interviews.
It was not a political thing.
Then, all of a sudden,
(hands smacking)
politics becomes relevant on
what we're doing with COVID.
And then, I said, "No,
we're gonna get involved."
- Your politics were
probably, you were kind
of right-leaning in
that you were probably
for small government, right?
- Capitalist.
- Right.
- Yes.
- Less regulation, less taxes.
- Blah, blah, blah.
Then, COVID hits,
and that's what basically
drove us both here.
I had a pretty freaking
good life in LA.
And then, on whatever
that day was,
March 17th or whatever it was,
two weeks to stop the spread,
day two, I was, like, "This
place is never coming back."
And you know, I
fought very hard.
I campaigned with Larry
Elder for the recall,
and I don't know if
I've told you this,
you know the three
days after the recall,
you know what happened?
- Hmm?
- You talk about getting a knock
on your door from the tax man.
I got audited by the
State of California
after I publicly was backing
Larry Elder and campaigning.
- Makes sense.
- I put my house for
sale that day, that day.
Like, that tells you
all you need to know.
So isn't that a weird thing
about how your life
better match up
with your politics?
Otherwise, you're
in a lot of trouble.
- See, I have a problem
with that because for me,
and what I mean by I have
a problem with that is
I have a problem with bullies.
You know, so here's
what's going on today.
You know, believe it or not,
the majority will forgive
people lying to them.
The government lying to
them, they'll get over it.
They'll cry about it,
but they'll get over it.
The majority will even tolerate
being taken advantage of.
(David laughing)
If you think about it, it's
been going on in America.
"I can't believe
you're doing it."
You're not gonna do
nothing about it.
You're gonna go back to
your state in California
and not leave, and
California's gonna be,
"You ain't leaving
anyways, so stop."
- You will tweet
about it angrily
for a minute.
- But you're not gonna
do nothing.
do anything.
- There is no action.
It's just, "Yeah, watch
what I'm gonna do.
Watch. Oh, yeah?
I'm gonna punch
you in the face."
Go ahead.
- Yeah.
- "Whoa, whoa whoa, whoa, whoa."
And then, you get back in your
car, and you leave, right?
That's most people
in California.
But here's the problem.
You crossed the line with kids.
Yeah, you just woke up an animal
because a mother went
through 40 weeks.
So mothers automatic, most
vested thing you're gonna be
in your life is carrying a
human being for 40 weeks.
You haven't gone
through the pain.
You wanna groom my kids.
I'm good, man.
We're not gonna do this.
All of a sudden, "What
the hell happened
to this guy's, you know, rage?
I've never seen
you be like this.
What happened to
all these mothers?
all these parents?"
California, UK, you know,
Texas, New York, what?
They're waking up,
so here's the part.
For most part, most people,
there's a saying that says,
"Whatever you don't hate,
you'll learn to tolerate."
Most people just don't
like it, you know?
But a few of us have a
lower tolerance level
for you crossing the line.
- I want you to continue,
but what do you think
that is about us?
Like, now I know.
Now, as a father, I
know a new layer of it.
But what do you think that is?
What do you think it is
about you that is just, like,
"I will be one of the people
that will call
out the bullshit?"
- Yeah.
I don't know how to
answer that question.
I would say for me it's
either in your DNA.
It's either, you know,
you've gone through
losing things in the past,
or you've had a
moment in your life
where you weren't paranoid,
and you lost it all.
And you're like, "Damn, I
should have been paranoid."
Or you were too tolerant,
and things were taken
away from you, or
you were kinda like,
"Yeah, he's gonna be
here all the time,"
and then boom, he's no
longer, he dies, or she dies.
So you have a
different level of,
and like, when you
read Musk's book,
you realize why he's
doing what he's doing
because of the pain
he's gone through.
Some of us have
lived a harder life
where, you know, we are
willing to use that pain
to do something about it.
But what I am saying
is the fact that,
so I used to pray for
four things, right?
For the longest time,
it's always been,
as Bet-David family, we lead,
respect, we improve, we love.
We don't get bullied,
and we don't bully.
And we pray for four things,
courage, wisdom,
tolerance, understanding,
courage, because if
your vision is big,
you're gonna do something big.
You're gonna face certain things
that you don't
know how to handle.
You need courage.
Wisdom, if you're planning
on leading everybody,
you're gonna sometimes lead
people smarter than you
and older than you.
You need wisdom.
Tolerance, because you know,
people are annoying at times.
You gotta tolerate them.
And last but not least,
understanding, everyone's
dealing with something,
so it's good to have some
understanding, right?
But the tolerance part, I'm
not praying about it anymore.
I skip through it.
I say, "God, I
ask you to give me
courage, wisdom,
and understanding."
I don't want tolerance.
Why not?
The reason why I don't
want tolerance is
because tomorrow I have a
big show on PBD podcast,
and by the way, we've been
working on this for months,
and it got ugly, but we
finally pulled it off.
I have two Muslims
coming on the podcast,
and I have two Christians
coming on the podcast.
- Hmm.
- Till this morning,
it wasn't happening.
Both camp backed
out and backed out,
and we had to change some names
because they couldn't
get their passports.
But we finally got 'em to
be here tomorrow, okay?
So we're doing this
conversation together,
and my goal is
we can have a
friendly conversation,
you know, what about this
with Prophet Mohammed?
What about this with,
you know, jihad,
and what about this
with Christians?
This, and what about this
one, and what about this,
and what about this?
No problem.
What do Jews, Christians,
and Muslims have in common?
That's my interest.
We can have the religion debate.
Let's do it, great.
By the way, everybody
could be wrong,
and everybody could be right,
and only one person
could be right.
And we don't know.
That's why it's called faith.
- Yeah.
- Faith is believing something
that we have not seen, right?
It's faith.
Now, I'm a man of faith.
I believe in God.
The risk I'm taking is being
non-denominational Christian.
I could be wrong, but that's
what I'm banking on, right?
I will not know till I die.
Now, there's been many
moments in my life to validate
that I've chosen
the right faith.
But that's one on one, right?
I can simply tell my testimony.
You can say, "You know what?
What a powerful testimony.
Let me consider it as well."
But it's one on one, right?
Okay, (sighs) look
what's going on.
Like, when I study
numbers, I'm like,
"How are 74% of Muslims
voting Democrat?"
It makes no sense to me.
How, how?
Why are Christians so critical
of the Muslim religion?
Yet, just so you know,
Christians, by 2060,
the world's gonna have
10 billion people.
3 billion's gonna be Muslim.
That's 31%, and
most of the Senate
and the House will be Muslims.
"How could you say
something like that?"
Because they have 2.9 kids
per woman, and you don't,
because they have
more kids than you
because they're more
vested in their faith
and more intolerant about
disrespecting their faith.
And Christians
are more tolerant.
Christians are
more similar, say-
- Look what's happening
in Glendale, the place
that you used to work.
- Ooh, Armenians are
not tolerant.
- I had a studio there.
No, no, but the
Muslims and Armenians
of Glendale decided to stand up
against the woke.
- And I love that.
- Yeah, that was amazing.
- And that's exactly what-
- And the left didn't know
what to do with it, right?
- And I love that.
That's my whole purpose, the
premise of what I'm trying
to do with these guys tomorrow.
I trust it's gonna be fiery,
but I'm gonna ask questions
that I'm gonna say,
"Look, if religion's
where you wanna compete,
then go have more kids.
You're not doing it.
You're gonna lose.
Just so you know,
you're going to lose
because they don't tolerate
disrespect to their religion.
You do.
They have more kids.
They believe in having more kids
and spreading their
values and principles.
You don't.
You're going to lose."
It's just going to happen
if it goes this way.
Now, that's one part.
Set that aside.
What's the other part?
Muslims, why 74% Democrat?
Why?
Just because of one policy?
You vote Dem just
because of one policy?
What's the one policy?
Just because Republicans are
a little bit more pro-Israel?
So you go this way, seriously?
That's the only reason?
- Which by the way,
on the war front,
the parties have completely
flipped, but that-
- Completely flipped, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So I'm trying to get-
- If that's the argument, yeah.
- I'm trying to get that
conversation for them to,
"Are you on the same
page with X, Y, Z?"
"Yes."
"Are you on the same
page what's going on?
"Yes."
"Are you pro marriage?
Are you pro-family?
Are you pro this?
Are you pro that?"
"Yes."
Listen guys, what are we doing?
Because the scariest thing's
gonna happen to globalists
and the establishment if all
of a sudden they see Jews,
Christians, and Muslims
being on the same page,
they're gonna be like, "Wait
a minute guys, no, no, no.
You guys can't get along.
We've worked so hard to make
sure you guys hate each other.
We have to keep these
guys hating each other.
Spread a rumor.
Bring an old tweet.
Did you see what
he said about Jews?
Did you see what he
said about Muslims?
said about Christians?"
And it's, like, "Yeah,
let's stoke more fire.
and that's why we
can't like this guy."
I'm trying to get these guys
because if Christians,
Jews, and Christians,
Christians, Jews, and
Muslims come like this,
I think they're gonna
be shivering, saying,
"How the hell do we go up
against these guys now?"
- Can I give you a good
one that maybe you can drop
with these guys tomorrow-
- Yeah, yeah.
- is that I took my whole team,
we did a week in Israel,
and then we went to Hungary.
And we went to Jerusalem,
first four days in Jerusalem.
Guess what the most surprising
thing about Jerusalem was.
- What's that?
- It wasn't religion.
Obviously, there's
religious people.
It was the peace.
There are Muslim women
in hijabs walking
next to ultra Orthodox
Jewish guys, hats,
Muslim nurses going to school,
and the Jews walking by,
and Orthodox Christians,
and Greek Orthodox,
and everyone's doing it.
And yes, some bad stuff
happens occasionally.
Find out what happened
in Chicago this weekend,
and it's far worse, but the
level of coexistence and peace-
- Yeah.
- it felt peaceful to me.
That's what I kept
saying to the guys.
"Well, isn't this"-
- I love that.
- "peaceful."
- Peaceful.
- Yeah, I love that.
- And that's the thing
that you're basically
asking for and looking for.
- Yeah, so I mean, look
at our show, right?
I mean, you know, I'm
talking to Chris Cuomo,
and we're building a
relationship together.
I'm not supposed to get
along with Chris Cuomo
for a lot of different
things policy-wise,
but then I'm having
conversations with-
- I've made fun of that guy
an awful lot on this show.
- I think we all have,
and he's made fun of us.
(David laughing)
And by the way, guess what?
Game, you know,
I'm okay with that.
I don't care if
you make fun of me.
I'm okay.
- Yeah.
- Sometimes I deserve
to be made fun of.
Sometimes you deserve
Sometimes he deserves
to be made fun of.
That's part of the game.
You know, when you're
playing basketball,
and, you know, Barkley
elbows Jordan in the rib,
and then Jordan does back,
"Hey, you know what?
I'm a competitor.
You are, too, great.
Your goal should
be to kick my ass."
And my goal is to give a fight.
Now, Barkley never got a ring.
Jordan took it, and the
two years he had a chance,
Olajuwon took it,
no problem, right?
(David clearing throat)
That's right. I see
that over there.
Just so you know,
it's the first thing I saw-
- There was another guy
on that Olajuwon team.
- Drexler.
- Thank you.
A top-50-
- player of all time, you know?
- Well, yes, I would say top 50,
top 20 of the '80s and '90s.
- He's not top 20.
I think he's top 15.
- He's not top 20 of all time.
- He's top 15, '80s
and '90s in my opinion.
For a 10-year period, I think
he's top 15, monster, monster,
28-point season average,
you know, whatever.
So going back to it, I think
it's okay to grapple and fight.
I think it's okay.
Like, you know, one of
the things we can learn
from the UFC is these guys are
talking shit to each other.
And at the end of the fight,
they get on their knees, and
they hug each other, right?
Dude, you have to
know, for showmanship,
Dana White needs a fight,
but he's okay if you
wanna hug after the fight.
But up until that point,
he wants to fight.
We want the fight as fans.
We want you to hate each
other up till the fight.
And then afterwards, guess
what we all wanna see,
as weird as this sound.
You love these guys
talk, "I'm gonna do this,
I'm gonna do that,
I'm gonna do this,"
and then, at the end of the,
hey, boom, head to head.
We get emotional.
- Did you ever see,
I haven't thought
about this in 20 years.
Did you ever see there was an
interview that Mike Tyson did
after one of his fights?
He beats somebody senseless-
- Yeah.
- like, you know,
at the peak of Tyson when he
was just six-second fights.
Like, he beat someone senseless.
I can't remember who it was.
And remember Jim Gray was the
NBC Sports guy at the time,
and they would just
throw him out there.
And Jim Gray was this
little, like, little kind
of frail white guy, and
he'd get in the ring
with all these big guys, and
he looked afraid all the time.
And he'd get there.
He'd be like, "What do
you think of the fight?
And Mike Tyson said
exactly what you just said.
He said, "He's got
a family to feed.
I've got a family to feed.
This is what we do.
This is why we do it."
- See, that's the part.
- Yeah, and Jim Gray
is like, you know,
"Don't hit me."
- That's not the answer
he wants.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But guess what.
We don't want that
answer before the fight.
We want it after the fight.
We're okay with that.
So, for me, I wanted
to create a safe space
where people from
the left, the right,
the middle can come and talk,
people who are Democrats
who don't want to talk politics,
but their sports, their
TV, their celebrities,
they feel safe coming
and talking, right?
You know, people
who are athletes,
they feel safe
coming, and talking,
and you know, doing
what they're doing.
But it's like, "You know what?
I don't agree with Pat, but
you know, I like his approach.
I don't agree with
such and such,
but I like their approach."
Cool, no problem.
So it's more trying
to go like this.
I think we've gone like that.
I think we need to
bring, so this book,
one of the best books I've ever
read that no one ever read,
you know, guy sold seven copies,
and I bought all seven of them.
(David laughing)
This book is called
"Barbarians to Bureaucrats,"
written by Lawrence Miller.
I've probably-
- That's a great title.
- over the last 13 years-
- have probably sold 30,000
copies of this guy's book.
Every chance I get, I
recommend this book, right?
It was written, like, if you
can get a copy, good for you.
It's hard to find one.
So he talks about the
evolution every society
and company goes through, okay?
So he says, you know,
in every great business
there's three people.
There's the entrepreneur,
the businessman,
and the son of a bitch, okay?
And he explains how
Steve Jobs had an element
of a son of a
bitch, but you know,
the other guy was
more the product guy.
So, 'kay, and he says,
so here's the evolution.
First, there's a prophet.
The prophet sells a vision.
"One day," like
that Jack Ma video,
"We gonna build
Alibaba and da, da."
You've seen that video, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- "One day," he's the prophet.
Steve Jobs, "One day, we
are different," right?
You know, it's Benjamin Rush.
- It's Matt Damon in "Air,"
which I know you're
big on the movie "Air."
- Sonny Vaccaro, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- "Hey, Michael, no
one's gonna remember us.
They're gonna remember you,
but you're gonna go through,
just like you go up,
you're gonna fall,
and we're gonna be here for
you, and da, da, da, da."
What a fricking speech, right?
When he gave it in that
movie, I got the chills.
I watched that
movie three times-
- You took your whole team-
- in the first week.
- to that after, right?
- Twice, twice.
- Yeah, that's great.
- It was powerful.
- I saw it after you
were so high on it.
- Yeah.
- And I was, like,
"All right, I gotta see it."
- And by the way,
the day after that,
'cause the movie came out
when Tucker was fired from
Fox, we sent one of our guys,
and he was outside of
Tucker's house, I can say now,
for three days,
dropping a note saying,
"PBD and Valuetainment wants
to make an offer to you."
- Oh, and you did make an offer?
- We 100% made an offer to him.
We made a public offer, you
know, every kind of offer.
But it is what it is.
He's doing a great
job right now.
He's a formidable voice,
very necessary voice.
So the point is,
you know, he says
first there's a prophet,
then there's the barbarian,
who's the guy that's
willing to go do the fight.
Then, there's the
builder and explorer.
They build technology, or
they explore a new market.
Then, there's the administrator.
Then, comes the next phase,
which is a problematic phase,
so prophet, barbarian,
builder-explorer,
administrator,
bureaucrat, aristocrat.
America today is filled with
bureaucrats and aristocrats.
Mitch McConnell, Chuck
Schumer, Nancy Pelosi,
these guys that have
been around for so long,
they don't wanna
give up their card
of being a congressman
or a senator.
They're the aristocrats
and bureaucrats
that are ruining America.
But he says the way you save it
when it's about to fall
is it needs synergists.
Synergists know how to revive,
you know, reenergize
a nation, a company.
America today desperately
needs more synergists.
Synergists are not about
saying, "You're a moron,
you're an idiot, what a
dumbass, what a stupid this."
Synergists are
saying, "I disagree.
But you have the
right to agree with,
here's what my thoughts are.
Here's what I believe."
So our goal at
Valuetainment is doing
what it's doing on PBD podcast.
We're trying to bring
these guys here.
If you guys disagree,
cool, let's talk about it.
- Yeah.
- Great.
That's kinda the
approach we're taking.
- Are you amazed that
these guys are holding on
as long as they're holding on?
When you see, last week,
Pelosi, "I'm running again,"
Mitch McConnell
literally freezing up
in front of microphones.
- Yeah.
- Feinstein doesn't
know where she is.
They have to tell
her what to say.
Biden, obviously,
something's wrong, Fetterman.
I mean, the list goes
on, and on, and on.
And that's across party lines,
by the way.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Like, are you amazed that
it's just, or it's just
that's kind of the point.
- I'm not surprised.
I'm not surprised.
- That's kind of the point.
- I mean, look at this.
You know, a lot of times when,
you know, the establishment
in sports wants to criticize
the current players, right?
And they defend
themselves from the past
'cause it's easy to do that.
And they never wanna give
credit to the newer guys, right?
That one video of
Elon Musk crying
when he's doing a "60 Minute"
interview, and he's, like,
"Hey, does it hurt you the fact
that these men were your heroes,
and now they're
criticizing you?"
I don't know if you've ever seen
this or not.
- Mm-mm.
- Oh, oh.
- I don't think so.
I need see it, wow.
- It's amazing.
It's amazing.
You have to watch this.
- Yeah.
- This is when Tesla's,
like, barely coming up.
Every day, he's being
criticized, and he's crying.
He said, "Does it hurt
you that these are men
you respect, and you admired?"
"Yes, it hurts a lot."
"That they're saying what
they're saying about you?"
"Yes."
And then you're, like,
"Dude, look what he's built.
Look what he's doing, right?"
So for me, I think
I'm not surprised
that that's taking place,
but we need changes.
And we need some bold
leaders to have the audacity
to go out there
and do the fight.
And they're gonna rise up, Dave.
They're going to rise up.
- So that's actually a
great segue to a little
of the Trump-DeSantis thing
that I wanted to do with you
because you mentioned
before, DeSantis,
they've moved it on
you a couple times.
I have no doubt
it's gonna happen.
You've met him privately.
Okay, fine, my sense
with you and DeSantis is
that you like him
a lot on policies.
You moved here
'cause of Florida.
You seem to think he has
some kind of marketing thing.
And I think that's
probably right.
I think that's probably right.
Trump is a brilliant marketer,
and it's kind of
messy below the hood.
And DeSantis, the policies are,
below the hood, it's all great,
but there's a
marketing issue there.
Is that what you're seeing?
Is that kind of, like,
a rough estimation
of kind of where you're at?
- Well, first of
all, I made DeSantis
for some things to you.
You sent the invite,
and I was in Dallas.
I wanted to make
sure people knew-
- All good, it's all good.
- to give you the credit.
So I was in Dallas.
- It's all good.
- I got on, I came
visit, and then boom,
we flew back to Dallas.
I had an event going on in
Dallas if you remember that.
So, yeah, so I mean, look,
the other day I
had Larry Elder on,
which you and I both
have a lot of respect-
- Love Eldie.
- for Larry
and what he's done, right?
And Candace Owens
was on same week,
Elder and then Candace.
I asked Larry, I said, "Larry,
do you think the profile
of picking a candidate for
president has changed?"
"I don't think it's changed."
I said, "Do you think
maybe you're wrong?"
"No, you don't know what
you're talking about."
And we kinda got into a little,
I mean, in our show,
even if I agree with you,
- Of course.
- I want
a little bit of banter, right?
- How did you mean
that question?
- Here's what I meant by it.
Here's what I mean.
You know how, in 1964,
whatever the year was, when,
was it '60?
I think it was '60
or '64, one of those
where Nixon didn't shave,
and it was the first
TV debate ever.
- Oh, the sweaty one.
- The sweaty one.
- And JFK
- Kennedy went-
- It's probably, it's
gotta be about '60, right?
- Yeah, so you know,
Nixon didn't sleep.
He had a 4:00 shave, you know,
and John F. Kennedy
went tanning.
He slept 10 hours that night,
had a good meal, looked good,
calm, came, crushed it, right?
Well, guess what.
It changed.
It went from needing a voice
'cause everybody's, like,
listening to the radio
to now radio on your face.
"Oh, my God, he looks to
(imitating robot beeping)
Nixon, right?"
Who was probably more
qualified to be president?
Nixon.
(David laughing)
Nixon was more qualified
to be president.
- Yeah.
- But he lost
'cause the game changed.
So America wanted
to see somebody that
was young, eccentric,
attractive, well
spoken, calm, you know,
carried, you know,
himself very well.
Okay, today versus then,
if you go back and study
what percentage of the
campaign they funded,
the top people that put the
most money in their campaign,
Trump is at the top, I believe.
Then, I wanna say
it's John F. Kennedy.
His dad said he would
spend all the money
he has to do the campaign.
He ended up spending, like, 40%.
The entire campaign
was their own money.
Reagan spent, like, 9% or 7%.
You know, obviously,
Al Gore, not Al Gore,
Ross Perot spent a lot of
his own money, whatever, 50%,
Hillary Clinton, 0%
of her own money,
Biden, 0% of her own
money, his money.
And you know, Obama,
pretty much these three,
it's 0% of their own money.
Those that are zero,
they're establishment-
- Mm-hmm.
- Okay,
that spend 0% of their money
'cause they owe the
most favors, okay?
So today's profile to be a
president, let's take a look.
Number one, America,
we are very close to
the majority not wanting
a pro-establishment candidate.
So to be an
anti-establishment candidate,
you need to have FU money.
That's number one.
Bloomberg had FU money more
than any other candidate
that ever ran.
What was he missing?
Charm.
Okay, so you need to be
able to persuade and charm.
He couldn't do it.
- Can I tell you something
quick about Bloomberg-
- Yeah, sure.
- which is that I,
and I said this to Trump,
the night that I met Trump
that I believed from day one,
and I really think I'm right,
that Bloomberg only ran
as a decoy for Biden,
that Biden was number
one at the time,
and they needed Biden to
get through the debates,
and they knew he
couldn't debate,
and he was crumbling,
and all that,
and they needed to deflect,
so they threw
Bloomberg up there.
He willingly did it
'cause you remember those
two debates that he was in?
- Terrible.
- But it was all about
whether he sexually harassed
a secretary, and that's what
they spent the entire debate.
So instead of Biden-
- Brilliant.
- having to defend himself-
- I truly believe that.
- Brilliant.
- You know what Trump
said to me when I said it?
Trump goes, he goes,
like this, he goes,
"Ah, you know, actually
that's pretty good."
And then, he turns to Melania.
He says, "Melania,
can you tell him?"
Or, he says to me, he
says, "Can you tell her,
tell the first lady
what you just said?"
I said it to Melania, and she
kinda nods, and then he goes,
"Nah, Bloomberg just hates me."
(Pat laughing)
- I mean, that makes sense-
- But I really-
- as well.
- there was something to that.
But yes, regardless,
he was deficient of-
- Yeah.
- the stuff.
- So if you look at the golf
score, you got FU money,
which causes you to not
be pro-establishment.
This is why Vivek is getting
some momentum right now.
This is why RFK is getting
momentum right now.
This is why Trump won in 2016.
This is why Ross Perot got the
kind of numbers that he got
that caused George Bush Sr.
to lose and Clinton to win.
This is why Reagan did well.
This is why JFK did well.
Anyways, I can go on.
You get the idea, right?
So you need charm.
Then, you need to be
able to have a run rate
of having fame or influence.
So, Vivek, a year ago,
nobody knew who Vivek was.
Some people in our space knew,
but most people didn't know who
Vivek was a year ago, right?
So he started late.
Vivek's gonna be a
formidable candidate in 2028.
He's going to be because
he's gonna continue.
Whatever he does next,
he's gonna be having
10 times the amount
of followers.
He's gonna write a
couple more books.
He's gonna do this.
He's gonna do that.
He's gonna be ready
for 2027, 2228, okay,
formidable candidate.
What's the next one?
So we got FU money,
we got charm,
we got, you know, run
rate of being famous,
'kay, that your people
know who you are,
then policies, okay, policies.
If you take policies,
who do we put at the
top with policies?
Trump?
Do we put DeSantis,
Tim Scott, Nikki Haley?
Who do we put at the top?
I think DeSantis can
go against anybody
with policies, hands down.
I mean, listen, his
record is the best
when it comes down to Florida.
That's why you and I are here-
- At the end of the day-
- based on his record.
- where do people come,
and where do people go?
- No question about
it, that's the record.
And then, the last
one that I added
to the list was being
able to create an issue
that no one's thinking about.
And let me explain
what I mean by this.
And I'm presenting this to
Larry Elder, he's saying,
"Ah, you don't know what
you're talking about."
And by the way, I may be wrong.
- Yeah.
- I may be wrong, right?
So what does this mean,
you know, coming
up with an issue
that no one's thinking about?
"We gotta build a wall."
"What?"
"Oh, we gotta build a
wall to keep these rapists
and all this out."
"The hell is he talking
about we gotta build a wall?"
"I'm gonna build a wall,
and I'm gonna make
Mexico pay for it."
"Dude, this just got
even crazier now.
What do you mean you're
gonna build a wall?"
"Mexico's gonna
pay for the wall."
"What are you, like..."
(David laughing)
Like, you know, you sit there.
You're, like, "All
right, let me see.
What are we gonna campaign on,
healthcare, you know,
military, foreign policy,
oh, the war, or
taxes, or economy?
No, we are gonna build a wall,
and Mexico's gonna pay for it."
No one's even thinking
about that, right?
So the average candidate
that runs, they hire
some bullshit, you know,
political, you know, consultant.
And then, "Well, here's
what's resonating
with the audience
and da, da, da, da.
And here's what you gotta do."
"Okay, great."
So I think some of
these guys just listen
to those consultants too much,
and it screws the
whole thing up.
- So that's your
criticism of DeSantis,
that he's listened to
these guys too much
'cause the policy-
- Yeah.
- you obviously think is right.
- Oh, he will, are
you kidding me?
(laughing) Like, oh, listen.
Let's put him in a room with
no cameras and talk policies.
You know what he's gonna do?
You know what he's gonna do.
- I've done it.
I've done it.
- Yeah, I know.
- It's incredible.
- Oh, my God.
No, I mean, look.
I watched Newsom the
other day on CNN.
I don't know if you
watched it, 32 minutes.
- I watched it.
We played a portion of it.
- It's a clinic.
He did a clinic.
- He's so fucking evil.
- It doesn't matter.
- He's evil.
- Say he's evil.
- He is evil.
- You know he's evil.
- But forget about that.
What I'm trying to tell you is
I don't care if he is.
- Yeah, I accept that.
- He did a clinic.
The average person
who doesn't follow
what the hell is going
on, they're gonna say,
"This guy's presidential."
He sits like this.
Just watch how he sits.
- No, I get it, I get it.
- At the end, he says, "So
are you gonna run for office?"
"Oh, no, why would
I run for office?
Do you realize just two
years ago they recalled me,
talk about being humbled."
Man, that's the kind of
stuff that, you know, is
attractive to the
average person,
not the person that's
the policy wonk.
- So in a way, do you think
we will always just get
what we deserve in a weird way?
Because you're basically
saying there are people
who are good enough to do
it, who would do it right,
who would lead to
a more prosperous-
- Here's what I would be doing.
- society, and then
there's a show.
And how do we arbitrage
those two things?
- If I'm running the
RNC, I'm the guy,
I'm the guy that's
running the RNC,
I wouldn't take this job,
but I'm the guy that's
running the RNC, okay?
- They don't pay that much.
You're doing all right.
- No, no, no.
I'm not doing it.
Here's what I would do.
- Yeah.
- Okay?
One of the only speakers
I've ever brought
to an event three
times is Billy Beane
from "Moneyball," okay?
He changed the game.
He won 21 games in a row.
Brad Pitt played the movie,
you know, the whole nine.
And what is it?
Jonah Hill, I think plays-
- He's the-
- DePodesta or whatever,
the guy that says,
"The most important
statistic is not a home run.
The most important statistic"-
- On-base percentage or-
- it's on-base percentage
is what it is.
- Yeah.
- It's like, "What are
you talking about?"
"No, don't trade him.
Yeah, get that guy."
"Why that guy?
"380 on-base percentage,
410 on-base percentage."
"What? He doesn't
hit that well."
"On-base percentage, he
knows how to get walked.
He keeps his elbow in.
He gets hit."
It's like, "What the hell does
an elbow have to do with it?"
"Trust me.
The only goal is to
get on base, right?"
I would bring in 20 analysts,
and I would spend millions
of dollars, and I would
tell 'em, "Put a golf score.
Put a list of 40 reasons why
somebody becomes a president
of the last, you know,
50 years after TV.
And now let's do
after social media,"
'cause those are two
different eras, right?
"So what caused this guy to
win and that guy to lose?
Okay, what was the mistake?"
Some of it's gonna
be work ethic,
campaigning, going out there.
Like, Hillary Clinton
just stopped campaigning.
Trump was doing
six rallies a day.
She's doing one a week.
- Like, those last four days,
she did nothing.
- Yeah.
- He was out there.
- But when Trump was campaigning
six rallies a day during
Biden, and he wasn't doing any,
but it was a different story.
That was a whole different game.
We're not gonna get into that.
You understand what I'm
saying with that part.
That was, you know,
a black-swan event
that took place,
which is not something
that's consistent.
So I would take this golf score,
and I would keep
eliminating the bottom 10.
So we start off with
40 different things
that we'd look at.
Statistics, eliminate
the bottom 10.
Eliminate the bottom 20.
Eliminate the bottom 30.
Then, I got the top 10.
Now, I want to see what is
the most important reason
why somebody gets elected.
Then, I take the top five.
Then, what I do if
I'm running RNC,
I go, and I ask my guys,
now this is a complete
different job.
I'm gonna ask my
recruiters to say,
"I want you to give
me a list of 50 names
that meets these five
criterias with a score.
So run a golf score
on 1,000 people
that could be
potential presidents.
Put Dave Rubin on that list.
Put Tucker Carlson on that list.
Put, you know, Ben
Shapiro on that list.
Put Charlie Kirk on that list.
Put all these guys on that
list and run a golf score.
(tongue trilling)
Boom.
(fingers snapping)
I wanna go talk
to those 20 guys.
Schedule time with them
to come and talk to us."
They'll come and sit
down and talk to me.
"I think you ought to
consider running for office."
"You're outta your
mind. I'll never do it."
"Totally get it, can
I show you something?"
"What's that?"
"Here's the data I
got here for you.
Do you love America?"
"I do."
"How much do you love America?
You okay if America
becomes a shit show?
"No."
"How much are you okay with it?
Are you a tolerant person?
Are you willing
to fight for it?"
"I am."
"I think you need to run 2028."
"What are you
talking about, Pat?"
"I think if you love
America, you gotta run."
"There's no way I'm gonna run."
"You actually have a shot.
You're one of the only
20 people in America
that has a shot, and
my goal is to get
the best top-20
formidable guys running
for being a president.
You're on that list."
I'm gonna recruit,
so it's no longer
who they (laughing)
choose to run.
We gotta recruit.
We're just getting our options.
We're, like, "Ah,
these are our best?
Shit, here we go."
Instead, I'm gonna say, "No."
Man, by the way, I'm not taking
anything away from Tim Scott.
I think he's a sweetheart.
I'm not taking anything
away from Nikki Haley.
I thought she showed
up to the debate.
I'm not taking anything away
from Ron or Vivek
what they're doing,
but I believe we need
to run it this way.
Then, we go sell the
right guys into running.
I don't think that's
happening today.
- What do you do with
the lies on both sides
related to all of this?
'Cause look, I supported Trump.
I've interviewed Trump.
(laughing) I like
Trump in a lotta ways.
And I will vote for him if he's
running against a Democrat.
So my cards are on the table.
The lies about Florida,
the lies about COVID,
I could go on and on,
the lies about Fauci,
and all that stuff.
Like, what do you do with that?
You're someone that
cares about truth.
You've mentioned your
faith several times.
Like, what do you do about that?
'Cause I think a lot of
people are struggling
with that right now.
They're seeing the lies, and
they're having trouble kind
of connecting that to
the rest of their life-
- Totally.
- or their ethos.
- And I understand that, okay?
Here's what I've learned.
The more you study history and
whether you like this or not,
you can rip this argument
apart as much as you want,
some of the best
people that fought
for our freedom were complicated
human beings, period,
misunderstood, complicated,
complex personalities,
weird upbringing, difficult
to be around, strange people,
weird habits, weird
obsessions, strange vices,
just purely complex people
who saved the world.
These are very weird people.
Then, you can look at the
people that were proper people,
the people you like, the
people that, all the things you
and I value that,
what a sweet man,
what a this, what a that.
They don't have the dog fight.
I'm sorry.
History doesn't
favor perfection.
The people that go out there
and are willing to do the
fight, they're not gonna fit
the profile that
everybody's looking for.
Is Donald Trump one of the
most complicated, complex,
strange, you support him
one day, the next day, like,
"What are you talking about?
She asked you a basic question.
Do you know the difference?
Can a man be a woman?
Can a woman,
(David laughing)
why are you taking five
seconds to answer the question?
You just say it."
But you don't know
why he's doing that.
Is he playing with her?
Is he playing with the audience?
Did he just have a meeting
30 minutes before Megan Kelly
with his five people that are
trying to figure out a way
to give a new messaging
because he's losing 3%
of the vote in a, you don't
know what he's thinking,
but what you do know is
everything he's
doing is intentional.
He doesn't wing.
He's not a winger.
He is a guy that will say,
"Wait till you see
what we're gonna do.
Wait till you see,
wait till you see."
Wait till you see is kind
of like a salesperson.
"Wait till you see,
wait till you see."
Part of that is a
visionary driver,
future truth, totally get that.
But he's also a guy that's
kinda watching everything,
and sizing everything up,
and he's taking risk here.
Then, he adjusts.
"That message didn't work.
Let me change this.
Oh, that message worked.
It's pissing off
the right people.
Let me poke on this guy."
But to me, we're not gonna get
who we're, like, aspiring to
get this perfect candidate.
It's just not gonna happen.
- So since Trump has chosen
an awful lotta enemies,
I really like what we've
done with this shot.
Can we go to PBD as one shot?
One shot, look at that.
We got the book right in there.
That's very nice,
(Pat laughing)
"Choose Your Enemies Wisely."
Who are your enemies these days?
- I got a long list of 'em.
I got a long list of 'em.
For me, you know,
a part of it is,
you know, what people are
doing to the greatest country
in the world that
changed my life.
I'm gonna do my part with
the fight against them,
the establishment in a big way,
those that are targeting
kids to confuse kids.
I got four of them now.
It's a very formidable opponent.
The people that are-
- How much of that is happening?
I mean, you're here in Florida.
I'm sure your kids are-
- Oh, oh.
- going great schools-
- Oh, my God.
- and all that, but is it,
like, just stuck in the
culture that it even has
to come up for your kids?
- I mean,
you have to-
- Who are obviously
insulated from some of that?
- I'm still running
an insurance company
in 49 states,
and we got 46,000
agents that 15,000
of them are active right now.
So I get all the news from
all these different states
on what's going on.
They call me, and
I'm talking to them.
So we have people on the ground
that are experiencing this
in California and
you know, Riverside.
Then, you got Oak
Brook, Chicago.
Then, you got, you know, Dallas,
even some schools in Dallas.
Like, "Wait, this is happening
in some parts of Dallas?"
"Yes," and then you
got, you know, New York,
or Calverton, Maryland, or you
know, all these other areas,
they're going through it, right?
So you're hearing it, so
I'm not okay with that part.
And then for me, I think
in the media space,
I got a lot of enemies
and you know, some of these
enemies are making big mistakes.
Some of them, you're just seeing
that they're in
it for only money.
They haven't made money yet.
They've made a few million,
but they've not
made money, money,
so they're kinda, like, looking
for their first 100 million
or first 200 million.
And I understand that.
You gotta go through
making that first million,
then first 10, then first 100,
and then maybe you go
add the additional zero
and two additional zeros.
Then, you have the ESG
community, these Larry Fink,
these Wall Street,
Stateguard, Vanguard, Soros.
He's giving the fund
back to his son,
and he's running it now.
I think his name is
Alex, 38, 39 years old.
And he's very-
- Just took a picture-
- close to Bill Gates.
- with Gavin Newsom
the other day-
- Gavin Newsom, yeah.
- which they made sure-
- I saw that.
- to get out there.
- By the way, good
move for Gavin.
He's gonna need
that guy's money.
And you know, this, you know,
Open Society Foundation that
Soros has given $32 billion
to the last 30 years or so,
that's a very powerful nonprofit
organization, Open Society.
You gotta watch these guys.
So then, you got Hollywood
and what they're doing.
So we gotta find a way
to make movies to compete
against Hollywood and
what they got going on.
But there's a lot of
enemies, but to me, you know,
you have to be very intentional
in choosing the right enemies.
The wrong enemies bring
out the worst in you.
For example, let
me give an example.
Women who chose the
feminist movement,
they chose the wrong enemy.
Men are not the enemy.
What are you doing?
How many 65-year-olds
today who are single
with no kids are
coming out saying,
"I made the biggest
mistake of my life"?
What did they do?
They chose the wrong enemy.
Men were never the enemy.
Christians, Muslims and Jews,
they're choosing each
other as the enemy?
None of you guys
know for a fact.
You've not died and come back.
(David laughing)
You've never met Jesus,
or Abraham, or Mohammed.
You pray to it.
We all pray to it.
So what are the enemies
that we all see today?
Values and principles
that are being fought.
Would you realize that
Christians are thinking
Muslims are the enemy,
and Muslims are thinking
Christians are the enemy?
They're not the enemy.
(laughing) It's the
establishment and globalists
that are pitting you
against each other.
We're choosing the wrong enemy.
We have completely, most
of us, missed the mark
on choosing the wrong enemy.
And it's destroyed
people's lives.
We've lost decades of
our lives, some years,
some decades of, some
their entire life.
It's gone with, so you know,
the reason why I wrote this
book was more for people
to realize that we
all make the mistake.
You know, sometimes you're like,
"I'm gonna do it to
prove that guy wrong."
That guy doesn't bring
out the best in you,
but the other guy does.
But the other thing does, or
the other institution does.
So for us, we got enough of
the right enemies right now
where the driver, what we
wanted, again, God willing,
if God keeps me around
for 40 years, oh, my God,
and we're healthy, and-
- What does that get you to?
That gets you to 84?
- 84
- 84?
- Yeah, if God-
- That's the number for you?
- I'll go to 100,
but he dictates.
I'm gonna do my part.
I'm trying to take care
of my health right now.
The last few years, I've
lost four inches on my waist.
There's a few things I did
four years ago in July,
stopped drinking soda.
I don't drink soda at
all, and then, you know,
a few months ago, I
don't eat breakfast
except for Sundays, and
breakfast, my favorite meal,
I don't do breakfast anymore.
I just skip breakfast
six days a week.
So I'm at a weight
where 235, 238 is
my weight at my height.
I was at 258, 260,
which you wouldn't tell
if I'm 260, you know,
'cause I'm a little bit
taller, so it's kind
of going to stretch, but
at 235, 237, I'm good.
I have the right people
around me trying to take care
of my health and all that
stuff, but at the same time,
look, God can also say,
(laughing) "You think too
much of yourself, man.
Who do you think you are, man?
You think we need
you or you need,
you're gonna be okay.
Come up here and have
him go clean a cloud.
Who do you think you are?"
(David laughing)
And I'm okay with that, but-
- How much does that
worry you, though?
'Cause I will tell you this,
it's something that I've
been thinking about lately.
Like, again, I have the
things that I want right now,
and I have had a thought lately
that I've never had before,
which is, like, it
seems to me like
the shoe has to
drop at some point.
Like, if you have the
things that you want,
the life you're living,
the life you're supposed
to be living, like, that doesn't
last for very long, right?
Like, something always
is gonna happen,
you know, a death in the family-
- Yeah, yeah.
- whatever it might be.
- I've been thinking
about my dad dying
since I was 18 years old
when I joined the army
because my biggest goal
in life when I was six,
when my teacher asked me,
"What do you wanna
be when you grow up?
I said, "I wanna be a dad,"
because I wanted to be him.
He's a great father,
very good father.
I wouldn't be who I'm right
now if it wasn't for him.
He lives with me, and
I'm the happiest now
that he's in my house.
My kids see him.
My dream was for my
kids to meet him.
- I met him.
I met him at your house.
- You met him, yeah, yeah.
- I didn't realize
he was living there.
Wow.
- Yeah, and my dream was
for my kids to know this man
'cause I never met
his father, right?
So I wanted them to have
an experience with this.
But, you know, but
I know I'm gonna get
a phone call one day, you know.
We're going out to a nice,
my son's birthday's coming up,
so we're going to
the Yankee Stadium.
It's gonna be the first
time we're going as Yankees,
you know.
- Oh, we'll wrap with this
'cause that's a
cool thing, yeah.
- First time we're going
there, so we're gonna go there,
and take him to the
game, and then go
to, you know, the Jets
game, Patriots game,
and all this stuff
that we're doing.
He can't go.
He just told me
yesterday, "I can't go."
I said, "What do you mean
you can't go?" right?
We were just talking
about this today.
He's trying to convince
me to convince my dad.
He said, "I can't go."
He says, "If we go,
I'm not feeling good."
He was in the hospital for
five days a couple weeks ago.
He's 81.
He's had 13 heart attacks.
He drank and smoked
for 35 years of his,
he smoked two packs
a day for 35 years,
you know, 30 years until
he had his heart attack,
so the fact that he's
still here, super lucky.
Of course, I'm greedy.
I'd love to see him go to
100, but I have perspective.
And you know, a long time ago,
I realized when I would
debate as an atheist,
I was an atheist for 25 years,
and then I eventually realized,
"Hey, PBD, the bigger
your vision, man,
the more you need as
much support as possible.
And God's gonna be your biggest
support when you're alone,
and nobody believes
in your vision,
you're gonna need
to talk to somebody
that's gonna make sense
of this vision of yours.
You better get close
to the man upstairs."
So a lot of things that I'm
never gonna have the answer for
I have to rely on a source
that's bigger than me.
And that's the only thing
I can give my faith
and comfort in.
I'm gonna cry.
I'm gonna be in pain.
I'm gonna be emotional.
I'm gonna have to go to
a lot of walks by myself,
and kind of break down,
and go through it.
But you know, the grace that
he's given me, man, (exhales)
you have no idea
how big of a role
the man upstairs
plays in my life.
So the reason why
I'm saying this is
I fear those things
are gonna happen.
But the way I know
I'm gonna go through
it is the one source.
This is the only way
I can go through it,
only way I can go through it.
- We should probably end there.
Except you mentioned
the Yankees.
(Pat laughing)
And you are now a minority
owner of the Yankees,
which when I saw you
tweet about that,
I was like, "That's basically
the coolest thing
I've ever heard,"
lifelong Yankees fan.
I saw a Jeter just a couple
weeks ago in West Palm.
Had a great
conversation with him.
The guy-
- Oh, I saw that, yeah.
- couldn't have
been nicer, and I-
- Very cool.
- June 26th is
both of our birthdays, so
for many of my birthdays,
I used to go to Yankee Stadium
on our birthday and
blah, blah, blah.
But you're a minority
owner of the Yankees,
which, I mean, is that just,
like, that's basically-
- Coolest thing.
- as good as it gets, right?
- It's the coolest thing.
- So wait, does that
mean you're in the owner,
are you in the owner's box?
- Yeah.
- So there's one owner's
box for all the guys
that are the owners.
- Yeah.
- And you're just in it.
- Oh, and by the way, the
Steinbrenner's owner's box
that they built, it's
ridiculous when you go to it.
Yeah, I mean, when it
happened, you know,
get a call from a guy says,
"Hey, I know you wanna
be an owner of a team.
You know, can you sign"-
- Have you heard
of the Yankees?
- "an NDA?"
- And I'm, like,
"Yeah, two years ago."
I said, "Yeah."
He said, "What
teams do you have?"
'Cause I'm only interested
in a handful of teams.
He said, "Well, I got, you
know, the Memphis Grizzlies.
I got this.
I said, "Yeah,
it's cool, but no."
"Who are you interested in?"
I said, "Well, I would
say Yankees at the top
and you know the Lakers
probably post-LeBron,
but I would say the
Lakers will be second."
I'm not interested
in Lakers today.
But those are the two teams.
"Great, it's just
not gonna happen
because those things
rarely open up."
Well, one of the guys
apparently was 80, 81 years old,
and he's at a phase
where he's, like,
he wants to sell his
shares, and I get a call,
"You need to sign an NDA."
"For what?
"Just trust me. You
need to sign an NDA."
I signed the NDA, comes back
and says, "There's an opening."
I said, "You gotta
be kidding me."
He says, "No, but you gotta
go through a background check.
This thing's gonna
take 12, 13 months
and da, da, da, da, da."
So then, I applied, interviewed
with all the Yankees folks.
Then, MLB did a
background check on us.
God knows how long that took.
Then, eventually, I'm like,
"Listen, this thing's done.
It's just not gonna
happen. I'm too loud.
They're not gonna hire me.
They're not gonna allow me
to come in, et
cetera, et cetera."
He says, "Well, guess what.
The Yankees owners wanna
meet you in New York."
Great, I flew out to New York.
I sat in a room.
Randy Levine, you got
Tony here, the CFO of YGE,
you got Noel here, the COO
who's been with them since 1974,
1964, and then Hal
Steinbrenner over here.
I said, "You sure you guys
are comfortable with me?"
I said, "'Cause I'm
not ESG, I'm not this,
I'm not that, I'm not
this," and he says-
- You actually said that?
You went through the-
- Word for word.
- Yeah.
- I told 'em everything.
I said, "And I'm
just getting started,
so you need to understand you're
gonna be forced to tell me
to sell my shares,
and I'm telling you,
I'm not gonna be quiet.
It's the only thing
you guys gotta know."
He says, "We don't care where
you are, totally fine with us.
We're comfortable with
that, but we have one rule."
I said, "What's that rule?"
He said, "Hal's the boss.
We don't want your opinion.
The only time we want your
opinion is if we ask for it."
- [David] Hmm.
- And I look at Hal,
says, "I'm the boss."
I said, "Hal, you're the boss."
(both laughing)
So I left, and then we were
in Bermuda celebrating.
You know, family, you
know, we go once a year,
family vacation, summertime.
I get the call, "What
are you doing, Pat?"
"I'm sitting down
reading a book."
"Congratulations,
you're officially
a minority owner
of the Yankees."
I couldn't freaking
believe it, bro.
I'm like, "Are you?"
"Yeah, yeah."
You gotta keep, "Oh, yeah,
yeah, you know, of course."
And it's like, you know you're
going there, wife, the kids,
all this stuff.
I'm like, "Oh, my,"
and my kid was watching
one of the greatest
documentaries of
all time of Joe,
one the greatest, who
he won 10 World Series.
Why am I forgetting his name?
Yogi Berra.
- Oh, Yogi Berra.
- Yogi Berra's documentary,
one of the best documentaries
of all time ever.
Good luck watching it
without breaking down crying.
- Yeah?
- Literally.
- Huh.
- Yogi Berra documentary.
So my son watches it.
I'm seeing Dylan.
He's emotional.
I watch the documentary.
Then, I get the announcement.
(fingers snapping)
Then, we're going to
the Yankee Stadium,
and we're gonna go there
and show 'em around,
and they're gonna get a
tour, the entire thing.
It's a great experience, but
again, it's a dream, right?
There's an element of
I'm 44, but I wanna,
the people I always liked
and respected the most,
they had an element
of being childlike.
I don't wanna lose
the ability of being,
not childish, childlike.
That childlike element is
creative, is spontaneous,
is curious, is in
pursuit of something.
You wanna stay in that.
Like, I love looking at my
baseball cards, and I've become
that 13-year-old kid that was
dreaming about one day having
a Mickey Mantle card, like,
"Oh, my God, what if one day?"
So this brings me back
to the 14-year-old Pat.
I was just a kid.
I said, "There's no way
this is ever gonna happen.
Your dad works at a 99-cent
store," so super grateful,
incredible dream, one of the
items on the bucket list.
But it was a great experience.
- On that note, my friend,
you know how this
thing is gonna end?
- How's that?
- Is I'm gonna bring
out young PBD.
We're gonna play horse
on my basketball court.
- I'm gonna lose.
- That's right, in your suit.
- Tell you in advance.
(David laughing)
But look, 'cause I've
seen you, your shots.
I know what you're doing, 'kay?
(David laughing)
- Thanks, man.
- My man, this was great.
Appreciate you for having me on.
- Yeah.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop screaming,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full-episode playlist,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.